JACQUELLINE FULLER:
Welcome everybody.
It's so good to have a
great turn-out today.
I'm Jacquelline Fuller, and
I run Google Giving.
And it's a real pleasure today
to introduce someone who's
become a friend, and is one of
the leading lights of the
whole technology and social
media sector.
I'm going to read a little bit
from Beth's background.
So her first book, "A Networked
Nonprofit,"
introduced the sector to a new
way of thinking and operating
in a connected world.
She built on that in her second
book, which we have
over here for sale, "Measuring
the Networked Nonprofit." Got
the two biggest memes in the
nonprofit movement--
measurement and networking
in the same title.
BETH KANTER: And data
in the subtitle.
JACQUELLINE FULLER: And data--
oh, in the subtitle.
BETH KANTER: Using
data to change--
JACQUELLINE FULLER: Using data
to change the world.
You should have said Big Data,
and that would have been
really funny.
Awesome.
Using data to change
the world.
She's also the author of one of
the most popular books in
the entire nonprofit space, "How
Nonprofits Can Use Social
Media."
She's got over 30 years in
the nonprofit sector.
She's done training.
She builds capacities.
She's facilitating nonprofits
learning about these themes of
networking and management
across the globe.
She was named one of most
influential women in
technology by Fast Company,
and one of Business Week's
"Voices of Innovation"
for social media.
She's a visiting scholar at the
David and Lucile Packard
Foundation, as well.
And one last thing I want to
say about my friend Beth is
that when I was having lunch
with another colleague whose
in the space of technology and
social impact, and said I was
going to introduce Beth, she
said, oh, tell them this--
that whenever someone comes to
me who is maybe new to the
sector or interested in learning
more about technology
and nonprofits and social
impact, the first thing she
always tells them is to
follow Beth Kanter.
So with that, I'll turn
it over to my friend.
BETH KANTER: Great.
Thank you, Jacqueline.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, Jacqueline, for
that great introduction.
And it's such a pleasure to
be here with all of you.
And I want to give a big
shout-out to the VISTA folks
who I had the pleasure
of having lunch with.
And I always like talking
to young people.
I've been in the nonprofit
sector for 34 years.
That's how I got my start.
And 20 years ago, almost to
the day, I had a front row
seat at the creation
of a field--
how nonprofits can use the
internet for social change.
How exciting is that?
And so, I was telling someone at
lunch, I said, I've always
been driven by my curiosity.
I didn't have a brand
career plan.
I just followed my passion, and
followed my curiosity, and
desire to learn.
And when I started my first
technology job, I didn't know
a modem from a microwave.
OK, you're supposed to laugh.
But I was able to learn from the
techies, translate that,
and help activists and NGOs and
non-profits learn how to
embrace this technology.
And I've been lucky to
make that my calling
for the last 20 years.
And I've worked with thousands
of non-profits literally on
all continents of the world, and
people who are passionate
about that question of, how
can we use this online
technology for social change?
And that's what drives me.
But I also have a personal
passion, and a personal
commitment to service, like
all of you in VISTA.
And I have a personal connection
to Cambodia, and
that's why I'm contributing my
royalties to spend that young
lady, [? Kio Savan ?], who's now
entering her junior year
at college as a civil
engineering major.
And that will change her life.
And I had an opportunity to
meet her last summer.
And she said to me,
Miss Beth--
she calls me "Miss Beth,"
sometimes "Mama"--
thank you very much
for your support.
It's very important to me, but I
would like to go to graduate
school in the United States, and
I would like to go to MIT,
Stanford, or Harvard.
I said, OK, we'll sell
a lot of books.
So I was a really, really proud
that the book won this
year's Terry McAdam's Nonprofit
Book Award.
It's sort of a highlight
of my career.
And it was a bittersweet victory
for me, because the
week that they announced the
finalist, my dad, Earl Kanter,
passed away--
gave up this courageous battle
with Parkinson's.
But I felt blessed that I was
able to share that with one
last professional achievement
with him.
And to honor his memory, I did
a social fundraising at an
online event and I used--
I ate my own dog food.
I used the ideas in my book.
And so he gives us all the final
lesson on how to use
these tools, and get
better results.
And I'll share that with
you at the end of the
presentation.
So let's get to it.
My first book, "The Networked
Nonprofit," co-authored with
Allison Fine, was about how
nonprofits needed to transform
themselves from nonprofits
to networked nonprofits.
And the definition is that
networked nonprofits are
agile, they are adaptive,
they're transparent.
And they're masters at using
their networks, and experts at
using social media to build
relationships with
stakeholders, and to make the
world a better place.
Now what I've learned in
practice as a trainer and a
capacity-builder is that
adapting this new way of
working happens very slowly
and incrementally.
So I came up with a maturity of
practice model, and it was
inspired by this Martin
Luther King quote.
I keep it on my computer.
I love it.
It's, "If you can't
fly, then run.
If you can't run, then walk.
If you can't walk, then crawl.
But you have to keep moving
forward," OK?
So when I work with nonprofits,
I see where they
are in their transformation to
becoming a networked nonprofit.
So we have the crawlers.
And there's nothing wrong
with crawling.
Crawling's good.
You have to start somewhere.
How many of you are parents?
Few.
OK, when your kid started to
crawl, did you say that's bad?
No, no, no.
OK, so crawling--
they may need to develop a
communication strategy,
formalize it, outreach strategy,
or there may be some
organizational culture
issues, OK?
But then quickly, they
can get to walking.
And at walking stage, they begin
to link their social
media and network use with
results, but they're doing it
in terms of pilots--
experimenting with one program,
one campaign, or even
one channel.
And here, also, they are
building incremental capacity.
Typically, I see nonprofits
maybe invest up to 20 hours
per week of staff time at
that walking stage.
And then there's a chasm that
they cross to get to running.
That does require more
staff investment.
But at this point, they have a
formal ladder of engagement.
So they know how to take their
supporters from passive
observers to champions
for their cause.
They have a robust content
and engagement strategy.
They have practice to experiment
and to learn how to
apply and use new platforms
and new techniques.
And they use some measurement in
that-- maybe not throughout
the organization.
But to get to flying--
at the flying stage, they've
built their network.
Yay-- they have many champions
and influencers supporting
their work, and spreading their
ideas and messages.
They have multi-channel
engagement with their content,
and they are measuring those.
And they also have a formal
reflection, and a continuous
improvement process throughout
the whole organization.
So crawl, walk, run, fly.
And the framework that's in the
book breaks down 12 best
practices in becoming a
networked nonprofit, and looks
at them at different
stages of maturity.
And organizations can use this
to help move them one step
forward at a time.
The book, of course, takes
a deeper dive into the
measurement practices.
And that's what we're going
to look at right now.
So one of the big ideas in the
book is about, how do you
become a data-informed
nonprofit?
And notice, I'm not using
the word "data-driven"--
the phrase "data-driven"--
because "data-informed" means
that the organization has a
culture of measurement, and
a culture of learning.
And they bring their wisdom
and their data to
decision-makings.
They're not driven by the data,
and they're collecting
and using the right data.
So I have three stories about
nonprofits, and somehow they
all ended up being animal
welfare organization.
So how many people like dogs?
OK, how many like cats?
OK, how many like other?
OK, I'm sure we don't have
any animal haters in
the audience, right?
OK, so there will be
a story for you.
And my first story is about an
organization that I just love.
It's called DoSomething.org.
How many of you are familiar
with them?
They are awesome, OK?
Their mission is to get over
15 million teens active in
social change causes.
And they are my poster child
for being a data-informed
organization.
I got have an in-depth profile
in the book, but what I
learned about that is that it
really starts at the top.
OK, so five years ago, people
on their board, like Reid
Hoffman and DJ Patil,
who is the data
scientist at LinkedIn--
sat down with Nancy Loveland,
who is their CEO, and sort of
said, lose your gut.
All decisions should be
based on saying, what
does the data say?
But they didn't just say that.
They talked to her about
building the infrastructure
and the culture for
that to happen.
Now what's really amazing,
if you go and visit
DoSomething.org at their
office in New
York, you will discover--
even though they have a somewhat
small staff in the
nonprofit sector--
that they have three full-time
data scientists on staff.
And those data scientists, don't
just sit in the corner
and play with their
spreadsheets, and don't talk
to anybody.
They have an open office
space, and they are
collaborating with staff.
When they have a team to launch
a campaign, they have
to creatives, they have the
mobile team, they have the
social media team, and they
had to data person so that
they're always learning, and
that they're always measuring
their results.
And two of the mantras that I
picked up while I was there
were this-- and I thought
they were fantastic.
The first one is, tear down
those silos around data.
OK, it's not--
I'm the fundraising department,
and you
can't have my data.
It's everybody working
together.
And the other one that I thought
was quite profound,
and has really changed my whole
measurement practice,
was, spend more time thinking
about what the data means than
collecting the data.
So let me give you an
example of one of
their recent campaigns.
And here's where the animal
story comes in.
They launched a campaign based
on some research where they
found out that a lot of pets
were languishing in shelters
and being killed, because why?
Why do you think?
Because there weren't enough
great pictures of the pets
being shared online and
on social channels.
So they built this app where
they could recruit young
people to go into shelters, and
take pictures of the pets,
and then share them online
with their friends, and
encourage them to adopt the
animals, to do fundraisers for
the shelter, or just raise
awareness around these pets.
So they'd launched the program
on the Today Show, OK?
And so, whenever I tell
this story, I
usually hear a [GASP].
But they got on the Today Show,
and there's this cute
little, cuddly, squirmy
little puppy.
And Kathy Lee drops
him on his head.
No, the puppy was OK.
But what happened is that, of
course, it got captured, it
got put on YouTube, a video of
it happening in fast motion,
slow motion, forwards,
backwards, sport annotation on
it, and bloggers picked it up.
But what's important here is
that first sentence that says,
today, DoSomething.org
launched a program.
That link over to the landing
page, all of a sudden-- and I
was in the office when
this happened--
a lot of people started
clicking.
It happened on national TV.
The data scientists went out
into a room, and they were
actually looking in real time
about the conversion rate.
How many people were downloading
the app?
How come they-- and they were
brainstorming how they can
improve the landing page.
So that's data-informed
at its essence.
And of course, they have
now the results.
It wasn't just a matter of
people getting to that landing
page and downloading the app.
They had ways to measure each
rung on that ladder of
engagement, from finding out
about it on the Today Show up
to young people helping and
facilitating or adopting pets,
and less pets being killed.
All right, so this next
story is about a
more traditional nonprofit.
The Humane Society of the US.
How many of you know
their work?
OK, so that's Carrie Lewis, and
her dog Bella, who's also
featured in the book.
And Carrie and the Humane
Society are early adopters of
social media.
They were kind of the
front-runners in the field
five or six years ago when
people were still saying,
what's a blog, and
then when adults
weren't allowed on Facebook.
OK, so Carrie's been
an early adapter.
And I had her take the crawl,
walk, run, fly assessment.
And I said, yeah, Carrie,
I bet you're running,
or flying at least.
And she said, you know what, I
think we're trying to scale
being data-informed.
I think we're in the walking
to jogging stage.
And part of it had to do
with the silos in their
organizations, and the ability
to share data, and to share
insights about what was
happening in their campaigns.
So they decided to start a pilot
where they would bring
people from different teams,
and they would
actually do a debrief--
bringing their data, looking
at what worked in the
campaign, what didn't work, and
what they're going to try
for the next campaign, and
generate something called the
What Worked, and What
Didn't Work report.
And now this is starting
to spread within their
organization.
So more teams are doing this.
And one of the stories that
she also told me-- it was
great-- how of you know
what a swear jar is?
OK, like if you have kids and
you swear, you're supposed to
put some money in the swear
jar and not swear.
OK, so they created this thing
called the source code jar.
And let me tell you the
genesis of that.
Back in 2011, they wanted to
measure the conversion rate
from social media
to fundraising.
Like, how many people heard
about us on Facebook, and then
came over and made a donation?
What's our conversion rate?
Well, they couldn't track it.
Did you know why?
Because the web department
didn't want to use Google
Analytics source codes.
It was too much trouble.
So Carrie convinced them
to try a few pilots--
try it, let's see.
And then her team was able to
report back what they were
able to learn from it.
And the web team got so excited
that they started the
source code jar.
And that any campaign that
didn't have a Google Analytics
source code would have
to pay a fine.
And Carrie's happy to report
that they never got enough
money to go out for
ice cream or beer.
All right, last story.
And this one is about Upwell.
up is an ocean conservation
organization that works with a
network of ocean conservation
organizations, OK?
And they have adapted the lean
analytics, lean startup mode
for the way that they measure
and learn from their social
media campaigns.
So what they do, they
do a lot of
something called big listening.
They use a program called
Radian6, and they look at the
social chatter that's out
there, and they look for
opportunities around ocean
conservation conversations.
So once they find them, they
package content with their
partners, and then they launch
their campaign as a
conversation with the metric
of increasing the share of
conversation about the
particular cause--
whether it's ocean
acidification--
I said it--
or shark conservation.
They measure their impact, they
learn, and they spread
those lessons out to the
network, rinse, and repeat.
So let me show you
one example.
OK, so are there any data
people in the room?
OK, data people just
love this.
OK, so what you're looking at--
all the different colors
represent keywords that relate
to their causes--
ocean, acidification,
sustainable seafood, sharks,
whales, tuna, over-fishing.
And they use a keyword
methodology so they can fetter
out someone who mentions "Ocean
City, Maryland," versus
"save the ocean.
And they look at the amount of
chatter that's happening
around those key words.
And as you can see, the pink
ones is the word "shark." And
like, oh my god, more shark.
Why was there a spike in
chatter around sharks?
Can you guess?
AUDIENCE: During Shark Week.
BETH KANTER: Oh, you know.
OK, Shark Week.
Who watches shark week?
OK, all right.
Watch it once, and
you'll get your
explanation on what it is.
But so, a lot of people
are tweeting with
this hashtag, sharkweek.
OK, so they went in
for deep dive--
no pun intended.
And OK, so what's the sentiment
of these people who
are tweeting around
shark week?
What is the nature of what
they're saying related to
shark conservation?
So we have "jaws." Oh
my god, sharks, get
me out of the water.
We have "save the sharks,"
which is their people.
Those are the people who already
know and care about
shark conservation.
And then we have,
"yay sharks"--
shark lovers.
And that's what represented
their opportunity here.
Can we get the yay-shark people
tweeting and passing
information, and talking about
shark conservation?
So they worked with
their partners.
They did something called a
sharkinar, which is a webinar
where they brought
them together.
They talked about what content
they could share, what tweets,
what links they could share,
and they let them loose.
They had measured a benchmark
of what the conversation was
before, and they looked
at what it was after.
And did they increase the
shark conservation
conversation?
Yes, they did, with
the knitting.
So those are just three stories
of nonprofits that our
data-informed, and probably
flyers, or getting to flying.
So let me talk a little bit
about some practice.
Like rolling up your sleeves,
some practical things, some
principles, practices
of measurement.
And I'm going to go into the--
and no, I'm not going to talk
about multi-variant analysis.
I'm not going to talk in detail
about actually how to
set up a source code.
I'm really going to talk about
good measurement practice in
an organization,
in a nonprofit.
OK, so I go back
and show you--
one of the things I wanted to do
in the book was one of the
initial things that I
discovered when I
was doing my research.
And I was lucky enough while I
was at Packard that I had 60
Packard grantees testing the
frameworks that were in the
book while we were writing
the book to
generate the case studies.
I'm not sure I'll
do that again.
But we were in real time saying,
is this something that
you would do in your
organization?
Is it easy to do?
Is it hard to do?
Is it working for you, or not?
And so, we adjusted the
framework slightly, and then
it also produced all
of the case studies
that are in the book.
But all of that aside, when I
first got into it, there were
a lot of people who were
afraid of measurement.
Maybe they flunked math or
whatever, but they had this
fear of measurement.
So I had measurement cartoons
grace each chapter.
And this one says, "I know
it's hard to measure
engagement, but there has to
be a better way," to make
people laugh and feel at ease,
because my ultimate goal was
to turn help nonprofits love and
embrace measurement, which
would in turn improve
their outcomes.
So the first thing is having a
measurement discipline, OK?
I come across a lot of
nonprofits where there are
collecting data, but there's no
framework behind the data
to help them think about it.
So the book has a whole chapter
on Katie Paine, who
was my co-author's Seven
Steps of Measurement.
Pretty straightforward.
Starting with the goal, looking
at your audience,
cost, benchmark, KPI, picking
your tool, getting some
insight, rinse and repeat.
So one of the things that
sometimes is most
demystifying--
it's not so hard to define
what success is, or what
outcomes nonprofits want to
reach, because it relates back
to their mission.
But the complicated part is
whittling it down, and
figuring, what is the most
important data point that's
going to tell us that
we're successful?
And I use a phrase in the book
called-- it's not a KPI, which
is a key performance
indicator.
It's a KBI, which is a kicking
butt indicator.
OK, so what you need to do
is to gather a group--
your team, people in
the organization--
who are working on the project,
and talk about, what
does success look like?
And then, what's going to tell
us that, hey, we're kicking
butt on this, or we're getting
our butts kicked?
And picking that one metric
that matters to know that
you're successful.
Takes some discipline.
And that whiteboard
is actually from
the ACLU of New Jersey.
But they said, we're just
reading your book, we're
reading this chapter about the
kicking butt index, and we're
in the room.
We're here, and look
what we did.
This is what we discussed.
And it works.
The other thing that I hear
when I go out and
I talk about this--
and I think this is where you,
VISTA folks, can really be an
asset to nonprofits--
is I always here, we don't
know how to use Excel, we
don't have the skills.
Why aren't you measuring?
Because we don't have
the skills in-house.
We don't know how to do it.
So organizations need to improve
their data literacy.
Whether it means going out
to the many sources of
volunteers, maybe using that
LinkedIn board source tool and
finding a data scientist to come
into the organization to
help them, coming to Google
and begging, stealing a
Googler to work with them.
Or you, who are working with
VISTA, helping the
organizations that you're
working with to help
organizations get comfortable
in some of the basics, and
maybe handle some of the more
advanced techniques for them.
So really, really focus
on data literacy.
OK, then it's the picking
out the tools.
If I had a dollar for every
time I got asked questions
about measurement tools,
I'd be really rich.
I could retire, because it seems
like that's what people
are mostly interested in.
They ask questions about the
tools, because it's easy for
us to talk about the tools.
It's a little bit hard for
us to have measurement
discipline.
But when we talk about the
tools, it's important to
remember that there's three
categories of tools, and
they're going to collect
different types of data.
And you're going to use
different tools to collect
different types of
data depending on
what your goals are.
So we have content analysis,
like the up story.
And that's looking at measuring
well how messaging
is doing, or sentiment.
If your goal is around behavior
change or preferences
or looking at attitudes, you're
going to be doing some
survey research.
If your goal's around expanding
traffic, engagement,
or taking some kind of action,
or making a donation, signing
up to volunteer, then you're
going to be looking at one of
the analytics tools.
And I have to say, the
nonprofit sector
loves Google Analytics.
They all would like t-shirts
that say, Google Analytics.
In fact, I personally have one,
although it didn't match
my outfit, or else I
would have worn it.
So the idea here is, don't think
about the tools first.
Think about what tools are going
to get you the data to
help you figure out whether you
have reached your goals or
been successful.
And then, how do you know
who this guy is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BETH KANTER: No.
Who is he?
Who?
OK.
And you know his famous line?
You know the famous line
in "Crocodile Dundee"?
AUDIENCE: That's not a knife.
BETH KANTER: The knife, OK.
So he's in New York.
OK, he's in New York City, he's
getting off the subway.
It's Crocodile Dundee.
and some punks come up, and they
want to hold him up, and
he says, you call
that a knife?
He said, that's a knife.
OK, so what I say in analysis
skills, that's a spreadsheet.
OK, so this spreadsheet comes
from Global Giving.
And so often, I see spreadsheets
from nonprofits,
and it's just data without
a framework.
And so they are gathering with
their knife, cutting data from
different sources, and looking
at it in context against their
goals and their strategies.
So now that's a spreadsheet.
And actually, this is a
collection of spreadsheets
that I've been collecting from
nonprofits on a Tumblr blogs
called F Yes, Nonprofit
Spreadsheets.
OK, so if you really want to
look at other examples of
nonprofit measurement
spreadsheets, check it out on
Tumblr, and you'll
find this one.
All right, and finally, this
whole idea of reflection and
improvement.
We're so busy in nonprofits--
check it off the to-do list,
let's get it done-- that we
don't hit the pause button and
reflect about, OK, what is the
data actually mean?
And how are we going to change
what we're doing
to get better results?
And I love MomsRising, because
they have two organizational
processes that I just love.
And I love to see here when
organizations steal them.
The first is they do
Metrics Monday, OK?
So every Monday at their staff
meeting-- and they maybe have
a dozen staff members, if that--
they sit down, and they
have a section where they look
at their metrics against their
key performance indicators,
and discuss it.
And they may do deeper dives,
but every Monday, they're
looking at their metrics.
And during these meetings, today
have institutionalized
the concept called the
joyful funeral.
OK, because they know that
they're experimenting with
these new tools.
Things don't always work.
How many campaigns that you ran
were completely perfect
the first time you did it?
Of course, everybody, right?
But things don't go as well as
they should, and you tweak,
and you measure, and
you improve.
So here, if they find something
that's not working,
they said, we're going to
call a joyful funeral.
And what that is is they
actually have a formal funeral
for a particular technique or
tactic or something that just
didn't work.
OK, you know that Twitter
chat that was my idea?
And we got three people to
show up, and two tweets.
That bombed.
Should we give it a
joyful funeral?
Yes, I'll call the flowers.
OK, it's time for a eulogy.
They actually give
it a eulogy.
And when they're talking about
the eulogy, they'll look at
their data, and then they'll
reflect about, is this time
for us to stop doing
this completely?
Or is there another test
or another experiment
that we can set up?
Because they know that to get
a big win, they have to fail
or have some things not
work, or even to
have incremental wins.
So I think it's a
great technique.
So the practices are finding
the right metric--
that kicking butt metric--
data literacy in your
organization from within or
from without outside, finding
the right tool to get the
right data to know that you're
successful, making the time
for analysis--
getting a now, that's
a spreadsheet--
and also making time for
reflection and continuous
improvement.
So I want to end with a story
now about the final lesson
about social media measurement
that I learned from my dad,
and that I can share with
all of you, because I
think it's a real gift.
My dad was 91 when he passed,
and he was an OB/GYN doctor
for many years.
And when we were writing his
obituary, we figured that he
probably deliver
10,000 babies.
And he chose that profession
because he wanted a medical
specialty that had joy
and happiness in it.
And what's more happy
they bringing a new
life into the world?
But he had other interests
besides work.
He was an early adopter
of technology.
He was the first person to get
an Apple computer back
whenever he had.
He was an early adopter
of the internet.
He showed me how to
sign up for email.
He was an early adopter of
beeper technology, cameras.
He just loved technology.
But what he loved even more than
technology was the ocean.
He really cared deeply about
the ocean and ocean
conservation, but mostly,
also, surfing.
So are there any surfers
in the audience?
Any surfers?
Well, if there were, they'd
recognize that the board he's
carrying is a Greg Noll board,
which is a classic.
It's a big board.
And that's actually me and
my brother in the ocean.
So I wanted to find a way
to honor him, and
so I came up with--
I was going to do a social media
fundraising campaign to
raise money for Surfrider
Foundation for ocean
conservation, and also to do
an online memorial event.
Now when a surfer dies,
in real life,
they do a paddle out.
And a paddle out is where
they all have
paddle out in the ocean.
They get in a big circle
out in the ocean.
They hold hands, and they throw
flowers up in the air to
remember the surfer
who passed.
So I thought, given his love of
technology, I wanted to do
something virtually.
So I came up with an online
memorial where I get people to
tweak the hashtag oceanloveearl
during the
24-hour period, and
share stories of
their love of the ocean.
And the goal is to get as many
people to honor my father in
this way, and also
raise some money.
So one of the things I want to
get nonprofits past is don't
just count, OK?
Get beyond counting, OK?
Yes, you have to count
when you measure.
That's the first level.
So if I'm counting, I could
tell you all of this, all
these stats about the
campaign, and
pat myself on back.
Wow, I raised $5,500.
I got 128 donors with 87%
donating more than the
suggested minimum gift level.
I converted 85% from Facebook.
72% were strong ties, and only
2% actually even knew my dad.
And I'm like, wow, wow, aren't
those great numbers.
And that was about
the fundraiser.
And I could tell you
the same sorts of
things about the event.
That, wow, I had social reach
of over a million.
I got over 3,000 people
tweeting with the
hashtag, and so forth.
But get beyond the
numbers, OK?
Use all those practices
and measurement.
And I did.
And I want to tell you a
little bit about what I
learned about social
fundraising, and online events.
So the first thing is that you
have to set a goal, and you
have to do it based on
benchmarking, OK?
Now I have done personal
fundraising campaigns in the
past for happier occasions,
like my birthday, and I've
been able to raise $5,000.
So I thought, $5,000's
a good goal.
But sometimes, we're afraid of
not making our goals, so we
put them way too low.
Or on the other hand, we are
totally unrealistic, and we're
out of context, and we put them
way too high, and then we
beat ourselves up because we
failed, and we give up.
So benchmark.
Look at what others, or
look at your past.
And I did 10% more
than the goal.
The next thing is, don't
suffer from the too
small to fail, OK?
And I have done this in my
fundraising campaigns.
I would set my minimum gift
level as like $5 or $10,
thinking, OK, my friends
aren't that rich.
I'll give them an easy in.
And people donate at the
suggested gift minimum.
And if it's too much,
they'll donate less.
And I found that out, because
I did $25 as the
minimum gift level.
And I got a little clever.
I named each giving level
after a wave.
And I think the $100
was a cowabunga.
$25 was a pipeline wave, and
$250 were hurricane swirls.
And I had, what was it?
I had 128 donors, with 87%
donating at least the gift of
minimum or above.
So don't set your minimums too
low, and people will give
according to what
you asked for.
The next is--
see, my dad was the first
early selfie taker.
He experimented with cameras.
So I have a whole collection of
selfies of me growing up.
See, it's not just a new thing
in the last couple of years.
But what would happen is every
time I got a donation, I
thanked people publicly, and I
was using my Facebook profile.
And every time I thanked
people for a donation--
and I did it very personally
with a personal picture, and a
link back to the campaign--
I got more donations, because
I compared the time that I
posted my thank you with the
time that I got the donation.
And I found that 85% converted
from Facebook.
But really, the lesson here is
about social proofing, and
social proofing is modeling
the behavior that you want
other people to do.
In this case, it's, oh wow,
Beth's thanking all these
people who are donating to
this campaign, and I'm a
friend of Beth, and I've seen
what's been going on.
So yeah, I'm going
to donate, too.
So it's this whole concept
of social proofing.
So the other thing that I had in
the campaign is that I had
a continuum of ways for
people to engage.
From the high ask, which was
write a check or put in your
credit card, give some advice
to the campaign, share our
personal story about your love
of the ocean; to things that
were at a lower level, about
just sharing the hashtag or
retweeting.
And it's really important to
have that continuum of
engagement, because people are
going to come in and out at
different levels.
And there's a great article
about that at the Stanford
Innovation Review
about the donor
journey, the donor vortex.
And I applied that idea to this
campaign, and it works.
At the same time, you're
also supposed to have--
think about influencers
in your campaign.
Now, you know what
an influencer is?
Someone who can influence other
people to make a donation.
So while I had different levels
of engagement, I also
targeted people who were
influential within their
network so they could inspire
their networks.
And so, I had 11 different blog
posts or Facebook posts
from influencers that
represented different segments
of my personal network.
So at the nonprofit tech
people, I had the
social media people.
Because I was raising money for
Surfrider rider I had the
surfers behind me.
And I was also running
an analysis--
a social network map--
of all these different
networks.
Now the big blue one, that
one's my network.
But there were also these other
networks where there
were other influencers that
could reach into getting more
gifts that came in.
So this was a way to getting
influencers, to leverage your
network, and to think about
it in a networked way.
Finally, I know a lot of us have
been experimenting with
promoted posts on Facebook.
I hear it a lot from
nonprofits.
And what I decided to do, I
knew that if I spent money
with the goal of trying to
convert those in the amount of
time I had, and given the
campaign, it probably wouldn't
work as well.
But I had another goal of
getting people to tweet with
the hashtag.
And at the same time, I also
knew that Mashable was writing
up the whole thing, was talking
about the hashtag event.
So I timed the promotion to kind
of accelerate what was
already out there.
And you can see kind of the big
balloon of where when you
use a promotion like this,
it's sort of like adding
gasoline to the fire.
So you can't expect promoted
posts to create the fire.
But if you have where you're
riding a wave, and you have a
lot of buzz around it, you can
give it that extra push.
Because again, my goal was to
get as much awareness around
using the hashtag in the event,
and to get people
tweeting during that day.
And finally, this didn't come
from the numbers at all.
This came from looking and
counting up, what were the
number of people that shared
their personal story about the
love of the ocean, and what
were some of the creative
things that they did?
And I had something around 37
instances of people sharing
the hashtag with their
story around
their love of the ocean.
And what's great about this is
that if you've built your
network in the right way, it
unleashes the creativity.
But I'm also thinking ahead,
and I'm thinking about,
wouldn't this be a great thing
for me to do every year, to
raise money for ocean
conservation,
and to honor my dad?
And oh my god, I'm going
to need content.
And here, the network has
produced this great content,
so I'm not starting all
over from scratch.
And because I've captured it and
measured it, I have it at
hand when I start planning
my campaign.
So all this to say--
I guess my point with all of
these things is measurement is
great, but go beyond the
numbers, go beyond counting.
Use all those measurement
practices to really learn.
So in summary, these were, I
guess, my take-aways, and
hopefully yours, are having a
networked practice, having
measurement discipline
happens incrementally
one step at a time.
Don't try to have too much
change in your organization.
Also, linking social
media to outcomes
requires some silo busting.
And again, that happens
in small steps.
Data literacy--
this is a real need in
the nonprofit sector.
And it's great that you're in
the room, and I have the great
people in the room, because I
know lots of nonprofits who
would love to snap you up.
I was talking to a couple of
math majors at lunch, and I
was secretly writing down your
names and your emails.
And again, go beyond counting
your data, and really embrace
the learning from it.
So with that, I want to thank
you for letting me share--
[APPLAUSE]
and open it up for questions.
AUDIENCE: That hashtag,
was it oceanloveearl?
BETH KANTER: Yes.
oceanloveearl.
I broke a rule of hashtags.
It was a little bit too long,
but I wanted ocean, love, and
earl in there, so.
AUDIENCE: Are all the tools
that you're using for
tracking, are they online open
source, or are you using
software, hardware?
BETH KANTER: OK, so in the
oceanloveearl example, I'd
like to eat my own dog food, and
I work with a lot of small
and midsized nonprofits who
don't-- as you know, as you
all know-- don't have a lot
of resources and time.
So I've tried to just use what
is available out there that's
low cost and free.
So yeah, I use Google Analytics,
Facebook Insights.
I used a spreadsheet.
Because of that, I
pulled Razoo was
the fundraising platform.
And I use RowFeeder which will
gather up tweets based on a
hashtag, and throw
them in a Google
Spreadsheet for analysis.
So I use light, free tools, and
my brain, and my heart.
AUDIENCE: So for our group--
for the hands-on tech group
that is working with all these
different nonprofits, a lot of
the nonprofits that we work
with, there's always that
question, which I'm sure you've
heard a million times
is, how long should I spend
on my social media?
And I know that's a tricky
question, but any advice?
BETH KANTER: Well, first what's
behind the question?
Because does it come out when
you're having a conversation
about what you could do?
Or is it coming out from the
typical scenario that I see a
lot, and you probably see the
same, is that it's a small
organization, and it's probably
one person who does
all the marketing
communications, and it's sort
of part of their job at making
time to do that.
So what we try to look at
is, what are your goals?
What is your strategy?
What are you trying to do?
And does it fit with your
current capacity, OK?
And can you downsize or
right-size your strategy to
fit your current capacity, use
your measurement and best
practices, and get results?
Now if you want to start to
scale your results, we're
going to have to look at how
can we invest more time or
resources in this?
And so, usually that becomes a
conversation about, how can we
train and get other people
in the organization
to use these resources?
Or moving up to having
a halftime position,
quarter-time position, or
full-time position.
And I can also say that there's
lots of ways and
techniques out there
to be efficient.
Like, I've gotten really good
with tweeting with one hand,
and drying my hair
with the other.
And there are ways that you can
plan your day so you are
more efficient.
Some people--
I hear a lot, oh, do I have to
be on Twitter all the time?
I said, well, no, you can use
it during found time while
you're waiting in line
to get your lunch.
Send off tweets.
There's scheduling tools.
There's lots of ways
to be efficient, so
I'd also look at.
AUDIENCE: So the talk about
the targeting these
nonprofits, you also talk
about some [INAUDIBLE].
So what's different between this
maybe-- or key difference
between the nonprofit versus
like a Google?
BETH KANTER: A for-profit?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
for-profit [INAUDIBLE].
And also, how is people from
profit organizations be
successful and make
a contribution.
How do they adapt to
the [INAUDIBLE]?
BETH KANTER: OK, so I think
I heard two questions.
OK, so one was sort of the
difference between the
nonprofit and the for-profit
sector.
And they're becoming
more blurred.
And you might want to look up
the work of Lucy Burnholz, who
is taking a specific look at
different formats and the
different legal formats, and
the ways that they work
between nonprofit
and for-profit.
And from a measurement
perspective and a social media
perspective, I think a lot of
nonprofits are more similar to
small businesses, because they
typically have less resources
than a large corporation like
Google that may have a
department.
I think larger nonprofits may
be similar to Google, and
there may be different
departments,
there may be more silos.
And that may be as similarity.
I think the main difference is
that nonprofits are measuring
things that, aside from some of
the financial outcomes like
donations or people signing up
to volunteer, they're trying
to measure things that are kind
of difficult, like social
change, climate change,
saving the world.
And that requires a whole other
set of skills than maybe
measuring sales cycles
and product growth.
So your second question, which
I think was about how could--
I'm assuming you work
for Google?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BETH KANTER: OK.
That how can I, as, an
employee of a large
corporation like Google,
make a difference in
the nonprofit sector?
And I think most
corporations--
and correct me if I'm wrong--
probably you have a volunteer
program where you place, and
have volunteer opportunities.
I would find that person in
department internally.
It's right there, right?
Talk to Seth.
And if you have measurement
skills or data skills, my god,
could I have your card?
I know 15 nonprofits within the
last week have said, we
need a data person.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's what
I've been working on.
I'm an analyst for the emerging
markets, so that
Cambodia [INAUDIBLE].
We cover a lot [INAUDIBLE].
BETH KANTER: OK, well,
definitely talk to Seth.
AUDIENCE: As a follow-up to
that, maybe you can talk a
little bit about organizations
that are effectively using
volunteers to either help with
their social media, or help
measure their social
media campaigns.
BETH KANTER: Sure.
The one that comes to mind--
their name is the Analysis
Exchange.
And they pair people who do
analytics in corporations with
nonprofits, and actually a
student who is taking an
analytics course.
And they will sit and do a
project, and help them get set
up, and teach them how to use
their analytics program.
And while I was writing the
book actually, some of my
testers actually worked with
several of them, and they said
it was great.
Since then, I've seen-- and I
wrote a blog post about this
called "Help, My Nonprofit Needs
a Data Nerd." I've seen
more and more organizations
that are doing volunteer
skill-matching.
And one of them is called
DataKind, where they actually
place data scientists
with nonprofits.
I think also, I know you had the
good folks from LinkedIn
yesterday talk to you, and they
probably talked about the
profile categories.
Going to LinkedIn, if you're
on LinkedIn, and I tell
nonprofits to actually go to
LinkedIn and sign up for Board
Source, and start searching on
those different skills that
you need to recruit in-house.
AUDIENCE: And just internally
for Google, the Googlers who
are here, you can go to go/give
to find more volunteer
opportunities, including social
media and analytics
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Hi, Beth.
My name is Ling-ling.
I'm a [INAUDIBLE] serving
in Pittsburgh this year.
My question for you is that
not only is in nonprofit
sector, it seems like the
priority is really applying
for grants, so that the
nonprofit will have a budget
to do the job.
So we're talking the skill
budget instead of the skill
[INAUDIBLE]
or their mission.
And so, have you ever tried to
use social media to facilitate
the grant application process?
Or do you foresee that there
will be a trend for
grant-makers to use that piece
as an environment for
grant-making?
Because really, I believe that
we should talk more about the
scale of their dream instead of
the scale of their budget.
BETH KANTER: Yeah.
So you're talking about one of
my favorite topics is on the
one side, we have the nonprofit
sector using social
media to do maybe grant
research, OK?
So if I was a nonprofit, and I
wanted to do that, I would
definitely be looking and
listening and looking at the
profiles of the foundations that
are using social media,
and learning and connecting with
different staff members
that are out there.
And I would go to a place like
the Glass Pocket's blog, which
is supposed to be about to
philanthropy and transparency.
And there is a list
there if you go
into one of the sections.
You'll find this list, and
you'll see all the
foundations, and you can
actually sort them by, I want
to see all their Facebook pages,
all their blogs, all
their Twitter profiles.
And then as you start to dig
down into the Twitter
profiles, you may start to find
other staff members that
you can actually start to be
build that relationship.
Now in terms of a nonprofit
using social media to generate
funding, there is a story of--
it was an organization in New
Jersey that did young people's
entrepreneur programs.
And it has a name, it's
going to come to me.
It's a national organization,
and they have affiliates.
And so, the development director
had started using
Twitter, and she was saying
things like, sign up for our
golf charity event, and she
was getting crickets.
And then she said, OK, I'm going
to start figuring out
who's following me.
I'm going to start figuring out
who's interested in after
school programs, and who's
talking about that on Twitter.
And she found this person who
is the founder of a local
family foundation.
And she found them on Twitter.
It was one of her followers.
And she started talking
to her on Twitter.
And then she got invited to
lunch, and then the funder
actually made a grant of $35,000
to fund her program.
I don't think that, right
now, is the norm.
But it shows that there is
a possibility of this.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
question, because your last
advice really struck me, said
go beyond the [INAUDIBLE].
Really, if you don't have the
speech scheduled you, I really
want to suggest to you to give
a talk to the grant-makers,
because in the nonprofit
sector,
everything is so connected.
If the indication can come from
the money-giver side, it
would be so much easier for
nonprofits to budget our money
to invest into the social
media strategy.
Then we'll get the return
on that investment.
BETH KANTER: And I think funders
are coming a long way.
A couple years ago, I was sort
of taking that mantle up.
But if you take a look at, like
for example, the Case
Foundation, the Robert Wood
Johnson Foundation.
If you want to see an example
of the future, of a
philanthropy organization
embracing social media and
connecting, just take a
look at what Robert
Wood Johnson is doing.
And also, they did a great
convening in the field of the
state of social media
measurement.
They brought together and
started raising the dialogue
around that.
AUDIENCE: All right.
With that, we'll say thank
you to Beth Kanter.
Really appreciate it.
BETH KANTER: Right.
Thank you, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]